we'd like to talk about someone you may
not have thought about for a while the
Dalai Lama a man so enlightened he's
basically the original woke bei
according to a Gallup poll the Dalai
Lama is actually the sixth most admired
man in America and when you mentioned
his name to people in the streets
you can see how widely he's revered a
lot of respect inspiration from what he
says he says like Bloodgood quotes
here's some really great quotes about
life a lot of good things I guess he's a
peaceful man he's about peace okay so
he's peaceful admired and has some good
quotes that is pretty broad they could
be describing either the Dalai Lama or
Matthew McConaughey but what what
happens when those same people are asked
a simple follow-up what would you say
the guy
now I have no idea I'm not even alive I
don't know II just I'm not really sure
he's a very important figure for a
Buddhist God right no not a God he's a
better person he's a life he just said
oh like he owes the Dalai Lama
money he's alive oh I got to
disappear for a while that guy does not
around now the Chinese government
however have a very different view
because instead of vaguely loving the
Dalai Lama they very specifically hate
him they've referred to him as a wolf in
monk's robes and have banned his image
they've even retaliated against
Americans for even meeting with him
Britain's Guardian says China reportedly
banned Lady gaga
that's because she met with the Dalai
Lama in Indianapolis to discuss yoga Wow
not only is it incredible that they
banned her for that it's incredible that
that event happened at all Lady Gaga was
with the Dalai Lama in Indianapolis
discussing yoga that is only slightly
less ridiculous than Elton John meeting
ben bernanke on Easter Island to talk
about rumors now the Chinese
government's hatred of the Dalai Lama
stems from its desire to main control of
Tibet a region in southwest China and
Tibet was something of a celebrity cause
in the 1990s there were Tibetan freedom
concerts between the Beastie Boys and
Richard Gere even brought it up at the
Oscars that was when it was this kind of
if something miraculous and really kind
of movie like could happen here where we
could all kind of send love and and
truth and kind of sanity did Deng
Xiaoping right now in Beijing that he
will take his troops and take the
Chinese away from Tibet and allow these
people to live as free independent
people again
so but you send this thoughts send this
thought out send this thought we send
this thoughts we send it out right now
oh you know what I'm sorry there's been
a mistake the thoughts are actually
supposed to be sent to the producers of
moon lights this is not a joke
moon lights these thoughts are for you
[Applause]
take the thoughts but but there is a lot
about Tibet that you might not actually
know for a start it's larger than you
probably think
China say it's this area but Tibetan
exiles will say it's even larger
encompassing an area that is roughly a
quarter of China so it's very big in a
confusing way at which and this is true
is also how director Lars von Trier
characterized Willem Dafoe's dick
seriously he told reporters it's too big
everybody got very confused when they
saw it well I'm saying yes Tibet is the
Willem Dafoe's dick of planet Earth it
is surprisingly large the point is China
invaded Tibet in 1950 and ever since
they've imposed strict controls on the
institutions of Tibetan Buddhism their
temples and monasteries have been
destroyed and hundreds of thousands of
Tibetans have been killed and things
inside Tibet are still grim when Freedom
House scored countries and territories
for political rights and civil liberties
Tibet came in second worst behind Syria
and ahead of both Somalia and North
Korea the whole territory is a gross
human rights violation which is
interestingly another way that lars von
trier has described Willem Dafoe's penis
and perhaps the clearest sign of just
how bad conditions are is the fact that
since early 2009 a hundred and forty-six
Tibetans have self-immolated in Tibet
and China setting themselves on fire in
protest to which the Chinese police have
been less than sympathetic
[Music]
when the O'Laughlin German was on fire
Chinese producer came and he caught him
and bit him because Los Angeles on the
fires so the police closer you got on
fire so letters the police are demanding
the family to Los Angeles a family that
they needed a compensation for burning
of their own clothes well every part of
that is horrifying and China is
unlikely to loosen its grip on the
region Tibet has incredibly rich
resources from gold and lithium to River
supplying hydroelectric power and water
to over a billion people so they are
very sensitive to any perceived threat
to their control which brings us back to
the Dalai Lama traditionally he's been
both a spiritual and political leader of
Tibetan Buddhist sort of a cross between
a Pope and a president a pope Siddhant
if you will but you shouldn't so please
don't China has done everything they can
over the years to diminish his power he
even fled Tibet in 1959 under fear of
arrest and he hasn't been back since an
escape that was reported at the time by
the most British man who has ever lived
the young Dalai Lama revered by his
people as a living Buddha was reported
under arrest by the Rebbe's
but according to other sources is safely
in hiding one clear effect rebbe tyranny
is not wanted by these intensely
religious people
yes damn that unwanted creepy birds
tyranny down with those thieving
imperialists and goodnight to Her
Majesty's subjects in Bahrain Maltese
Rhodesia to make a Barbados Kenya and
Uganda
nighty night sleepy tight
for over fifty years
the Dalai Lama has lived in exile in
India and he's lived quite a life he's
met with the last four presidents and
when he was a child FDR gave him a
beautiful Patek Phillipe pocket watch
which he still has to this day and
George W Bush gave him an even greater
gift but painting his portrait these
portraits and I gave Bush his skills as
noticed the same review I give his time
as president not bad for a five-year-old
now
the dalai lama officially stepped down
from running the Tibetan
government-in-exile in 2011 but he's
still have profound importance to the
Tibetan people as a spiritual leader and
a figurehead and here here is where this
story gets absolutely amazing because
he's 81 years old so thoughts have
inevitably turned to his next
reincarnation but it turns out there's a
bit of a problem with that and let me
explain broadly speaking when the dalai
lama dies he reincarnates as a child
somewhere on earth and traditionally a
key person in the process of finding him
is someone called the panchen lama and
when the Panchen Lama dies the dalai
lama plays a similar role in finding him
and so on and so on
they're basically playing a buddhist
version of hide and seek
so the ninth panchen lama helped
identify the current Dalai Lama who in
turn identified this six year old boy as
the Panchen Lama but this is where it
starts to get tricky because that boy
has not been seen in more than 20 years
these are the last known pictures of
GERD and choking Nima the boy chosen to
be Panchen Lama the Chinese authorities
rejected his appointment arrested the
boy and his family it's true China
kidnapped a six-year-old and no one has
heard from him since although just two
years ago a senior Chinese official said
he is being educated living a normal
life growing up healthily and does not
wish to be disturbed which is a little
suspicious because it sounds like the
kind of thing a former child stars
publicist would scream into a phone
she's growing up healthy living a normal
life and those track marks on her arms
are just where they inject the vitamins
she's
she's fine but Jonah didn't stop it just
stealing the Panchen Lama if I had
another trick up their sleeve in an
attempt to discredit the Dalai Lama's
choice of one of tibet's top Buddhist
spiritual leaders Chinese officials used
a 200 year old ceremony to name their
own Pancham Lama
yes they made their own fake Panchen
Lama they basically counterfeited a
religious leader like a knockoff handbag
that doesn't say coach that says cough
and China's tactics here are obvious if
they control the Panchen Lama they can
use him to pick a new Dalai Lama who
might completely coincidentally be very
favorable to the Chinese government
meanwhile the Dalai Lama understandably
is pretty pissed off about this the
landing no I want to make clear there as
far as my own rebirth is concerned the
final authority is myself no one else
but obviously not Chinese colonists that
is some forceful language - he's
basically saying they can make that
decision over my dead body
except you know specifically not that
he's now actually saying that he will
either not reincarnate as the Dalai Lama
at all or if he does it won't be inside
Chinese control Tibet it will be
somewhere else which is incredible
because that means that when he dies we
could plausibly wind up with two rival
Dalai Lama's and the already fraught
situation in Tibet could spiral out of
control and for the time being there is
really only one person who can fill you
in on what is happening in the Dalai
Lama's head but he lives in India and
that is a 14 hour flight away and the
reason I know that is I went to speak to
the Dalai Lama in India enjoy
yes I travel to the Himalayan foothills
of Dharamsala India a journey that
involved considerably more uphill
walking cows and monkey traffic than
I've been led to believe all to talk
with the Dalai Lama about China
conditions in Tibet and what comes next
for him
you holiness it isn't honor to speak to
you may I say Tashi Delek
thank you how is my pronunciation - I
think we're good in my defense I just
started learning Tibetan 40 seconds ago
let's talk about China because the
Chinese government absolutely hates you
don't they yes publicly one government
official said you're a wolf wrapped in
monk's robes and photos of you are
forbidden in many places you don't to me
look like an evil wolf they just called
me sa demon you're a demon oh yeah then
I immediately yes I am demon with horns
yeah because that's the classic demon
right yes I think that's what I look at
you that's what they see oh why don't I
do one to say that's their freedom I
have no say no negative feeling I just
feel a laugh like that I practice you
see taking others anger suspicion
distrust and give them patience
tolerance and compassion I practiced
that but it seems the Chinese government
are particularly good at taking your
positivity turning it back into
negativity and oppression of the Tibetan
people they hand it back to you as it
was yes just outside the dalai lama's
temple is a local memorial honoring
Tibetans who self-immolated in protest
against Chinese oppression acts that put
him in a very difficult position this is
a hard question
well the self-immolation that has
happened or a hundred and forty Tibetans
yes
burned themselves it is very very sad
indeed yes why is it hard for you to
definitively tell them to stop doing it
this is I find a very difficult sort of
situation there right from the beginning
when I first heard that firstly i
express my solo or sadness then meantime
if I say their action is wrong then
their family they will they feel very
sad
what would our family member did
something against Inter Lamas wish right
I don't want to create that and then
certainly I cannot support that because
of the act of killing from Buddhist
viewpoint it's a self killing not good
so therefore my position is very very
difficult
so then best thing is remain silence to
quite the tango Lama is Priene fully
aware how powerful his words are and he
occasionally uses them in targeted and
sometimes surprisingly specific ways
like this example which he offered up
out of nowhere one will my previous
visit Mongolia is it they took lot of
vodka the Russians were hard ferocity
they like a drink yeah vodka then I
suggested drink much less vodka yeah I
love to hear instead of that you say
dead traditional drink horse milk wait
hold on hold me what you tried to wean
them off vodka by giving them horse milk
oh yes
then they follow what they really follow
since then say I think majority of
Mongolian no longer any drink hold on
that is a that is a huge claim you cured
Mongolia of alcoholism yes using horse
milk yes yeah not too late but the point
I'm just concerned I would see horse
milk and I think oh that came from a
horse
oh that's illogical once differences cow
milk and hospital one differences one
comes out of a cow the other I don't
know how you get it out of a horse I
know you just how to keep the party
going let's talk about a lighter subject
death you are going to die and when you
do it's going to be a massive problem
because there are issues regarding your
reincarnation regarding China I I do not
much done son what that by being cousin
is well-being of seven billion human
being and then preservation of rich
Buddhist tradition but which we kept but
you're intertwined with that no no it's
an individual person not much important
you know right but there is a loyal um
but Buddhism over two thousand since
early years still very much alike so do
you think you might be the last Dalai
Lama very possible you do yes you might
be if I become last dollar I feel very
happy what because you were a good one
oh yes I may say quite intelligent
oh you calling yourself intelligent so a
little bit of arrogance there as well if
you don't resolve your reincarnation
issue are you not worried that China
will appoint their own Dalai Lama and he
may not speak like you're speaking now
that also it may I say so yeah there's
also you see one of the foolish and
short-sighted China without using human
brain properly it's harmful that's that
is a guaranteed way to calm the Chinese
government down to tell them they're not
using the human brain properly I told
them our brain usually you see have the
ability to create common sense the
Chinese hardliners in their brain that
one brain is missing Z Chinese leaders
Chinese Communists they're very much
concerned about the image of China I'm
happy to sit here and criticize China
with you because I know the consequences
for me are not necessarily as bad as
they are for you so so I wish you see
they call me demon so I want another
demon so you become demon no no no you
can't transfer you can't reincarnate the
demon into me you cannot do that you
don't only do that SN de geneve Z oh no
this is not how I wanted this interview
today
so the Dalai Lama seems determined to
keep his reincarnation plans private for
the time being
leaving millions of Tibetans waiting for
an answer and as our time drew to a
close I wanted to cement our new
friendship you were given a watch by
President Roosevelt is that true yes
true at that time I think one cursor
better flip that's actually a beautiful
one pocket pocket watch right well I
have a special gift for you it is not a
beautiful watch from a president but it
is a special watch from me here it is
it's a calculator watch oh right
Roosevelt might have given you a fancy
watch but that is water-resistant
wonderful thank you Rosalie rosewood
watch I did old fashioned yeah this new
fashion well not so much new fashioned
as from the 1980s okay thank you
thank you think about thank you my demon
friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]